sister wives star mckelty padron and her
husband tony reveal their expecting
twins the couple shared the happy news
on instagram including this photo of the
ultrasound along with matching bibs that
say drinking buddies mckelty writes
we're having twins miss avalon will be a
big sister in december twins come
earlier so probably before then tony and
i definitely weren't planning this or
expecting it but we're both excited for
our upcoming adventure and all the chaos
and love it brings and her mom christine
brown is overjoyed about the two little
bundles of joy on the way the reality
star shared her excitement with this
photo of mckelty's 14 month old daughter
avalon and wrote in the caption we're so
excited it's incredible being in omaha
and now we'll have two more christine
echoed a similar sentiment to e.t last
year when mckelty was pregnant with
avalon it's been actually great for me
mckelty is pregnant so i i'm so excited
for another grand baby coming for all of
us um it's been fun so i actually we had
a
outdoor baby shower for her and we are
able to keep it all outside in her home
in st george like outside her home in st
george so i traveled down there to see
her and spend some time with her and it
was absolutely wonderful now mckelty's
father cody has yet to speak out about
the baby news you'll recall him and
christine ended their 25-year spiritual
marriage in november mary i can't do
marriage with cody anymore i don't want
him you don't get to give up like that i
don't want to do it anymore
and this past season fans watched their
rocky relationship play out the intimate
part of our marriage is over
and
to be honest
i'm not
okay with that
i'm not okay with staying in a marriage
where there's no intimacy that's not a
real marriage and while they were still
together christine told et she enjoyed
living apart from her fellow sister
wives i really like living separate i
like my own space i like my own autonomy
i feel like i like me better now as and
i just feel like i've been able to
really
like raise my kids how i want to i
really have more of an independence and
don't expect cody and christine's six
kids to follow in their parents
footsteps when it comes to having a
plural marriage tony mckelty joke about
it all the time but they both agree that
if blake lively asked they'd both be
very interested in pokemon at that point
um
my kids aren't open to living plural
marriage in all honesty like they can't
we've talked a lot through the years
just about everything
and
none of my kids are going to live
our lifestyle for now that lifestyle
means double the fun congrats to mckelty
and tony on their growing family
[Music]